our calendar is just a mess it's a very
complicated mismatch of different cycles
and different lengths of time and every
once in a while we have to make an
adjustment to those lengths of time to
to make things match one way we do that
is every once in a while adding an extra
day to our calendar and that extra day
is February 29th when we have an extra
day we call that year a leap year
so there are two fundamental units of
time that we use that are tied to actual
physical events one is the day and
that's the time it takes for the earth
to make one rotation around its axis the
other is the year and that's the time it
takes the earth to make one revolution
in its orbit around the Sun every other
unit we use the week the second the hour
is fairly arbitrary but those two are
tied to actual physical events in a more
well behaved universe our calendar would
be a lot easier to deal with if 365 of
these exactly matched one of those but
of course that's not the way it works
actually our year is made up of about
365 and a quarter days that means that
every time the earth has gone round the
Sun once it's actually rotated 365 and
1/4 times if we rotate 365 and 1/4 times
every year but we're only counting 365
of them in a year that means every four
years we've got an extra day that hasn't
appeared in our calendar so we have to
put it back in and that's where February
29th comes in but that's not quite
enough the number of days in a year is
not exactly 365 and six hours it's 365
five hours 49 minutes and 16 seconds
that means if we do what I just said by
the end of a hundred years we've
accumulated too much time in our
calendar and now we need to take a full
day away so every hundred years on a
year that would have been elite peer
going by the 4-year rule we skip one and
we take away that extra day so every
time the year is divisible by 100 that
means 1900 2000 2100 we we skipped the
leap year and so on those years February
has 28 days and not 29 days except
that's still not quite right it was an
extra bit that we need to correct again
because now every 400 years
we've missed an extra day so now every
400 years we reverse that rule and we
add the leap year back in so this
becomes very complicated but the
fundamental rule is for a given year if
the year is divisible by 4 then it's a
leap year unless the year is divisible
by 100 in which case it's not a leap
year unless the year is divisible by 400
in which case it's a leap year and we
have February twenty-ninth the mismatch
between the rotation of the earth and
the revolution around the Sun is such
that that extra amount of time is taken
care of fairly to a fairly high
precision by all these actual
Corrections in actual fact it still
means that we will need an extra
correction at the end of 3,200 years but
that's not actually built into our
calendar we stopped at the end of 400
years in these Corrections Oh
astronomers are used to dealing with all
sorts of not very convenient measurement
systems that's unfortunately the legacy
of our very historical science so we are
used to dealing with this and if we need
to calculate the number of days that
have passed between two dates it does
become very complicated if you have to
calculate how many months and how many
days in that month and whether they're
elite peers involved we simplify that by
using our own calendar for the passage
of time known as Julian date and all
that is is a single number that counts
the number of days that have gone by
since a very distant date in the past
zero point of that calendar is January
first Monday January first 4713 BC 12:00
noon
Greenwich Mean Time and of course being
here in Nottingham that's our time zone
the Greenwich we're in the same time
zone as the Greenwich meridian by that
reckoning February 29th 2012 is Julian
date two four five five nine eight seven
yes right you can add a decimal place
after that date
which records purely the decimal
fraction of the day that's gone by one
Julian date is equal to one one day so
if you hear Julian date that ends with a
0.5 that means half a day has passed in
addition to the full day that is
counting yes this is going to sound
familiar to a lot of people because of
course in the Star Trek universe
you often hear captain's log stardate
245 5.73 which is a similar kind of
concept but the Star Trek writers and
producers deliberately didn't make it an
official fast fast and fixed rule as to
what a stardate meant so that they could
factor in all of the different concepts
like speed of travel and different parts
of the galaxy and that sort of thing so
stardate is not the same as Julian date
yeah so normally I would probably record
the date of an observation as April 3rd
2010 something like that because the
work I do is not particularly time
critical however if you're recording
something like a gamma-ray burst or a
periodic event like the transit of a
planet then Julian date would be given
to a very high precision so having just
said that I don't use Julian dates very
often here's a paper that I wrote where
I did use it so here I made a plot with
Julian date but I've subtracted all of
the large part of the number just to
leave that the cumulative number of days
here and so you can easily see that
we've gone from five four five to five
60 which is 15 days and that's a lot
easier than saying we've gone from
January 25th to February whatever in
that reckoning see I can't even do it in
my head
so a leap second is the same kind of
concept in the any idea that it's
correcting our calendars to make things
match up but it's not related to the
leap year at all it's purely adjusting
for the variable rotation of the earth
to make a day lasts a day